did you know that here in the Pacific
Ocean there's this huge deposit of
valuable Metals everyone agrees that our
future is going to contain metals like
nickel Cobalt copper and manganese these
metals are key ingredients to making
batteries which we need a lot of very
soon to get us away from this Burning
hydrocarbons to move our bodies and our
Goods around the world one way to get
all these Metals is to send giant robots
to the bottom of the ocean floor to
vacuum up all of these deposits and then
to send them up to the ship on the
surface but there's one big problem
which is that this patch of ocean isn't
owned by any country it's international
waters so countries are gonna have to
work together and establish rules on how
to do this properly and at this point we
don't know what the environmental
implications are of just digging up all
of these metals from the bottom of the
ocean this is just one of the many
difficult trade-offs that the world is
facing right now as we figure out
solutions to this climate crisis if you
want to better understand global
politics follow for more